In Sudan, the Defense Minister announces the removal of President Omar al-Bashir...
...and declares a state of emergency for three months,...
...after nearly four months of demonstrations against his autocratic 30-year rule.
In Britain, British police arrested WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange...
...after the Ecuadorian embassy in London evicted him,...
...the latest step in a legal drama dating back more than seven years..
Also from Britain,...
...British Prime Minister Theresa May has agreed with the European Union...
...to extend the Brexit deadline until October 31,...
...four months longer than the deadline she was seeking.
In South Korea, the Constitutional Court has overturned...
...the country's 65-year-old ban on abortion effective January 1, 2021,...
...unless lawmakers draft legislation to do so more gradually.
Finally from India, voters began choosing hundreds of lawmakers...
...in the country's general election...
...that will determine the fate of incumbent Prime Minister Narendra Modi.